So just a little bit of context. Um, um,
for a long time, obviously we were
subsistence farmers and then, uh,
we've had several industrial
revolutions over time. Um,
we are now on the precipice of
the fourth industrial revolution,
a pretty significant
impact on our workforce,
our global workforce.
What has been consistent for each of these
industrial revolutions for success is
human ingenuity,
human creativity and the for
us to create opportunities.
Um,
and I am firmly a believer
and an optimistic sort of
growth mindset that we will
always find enough work for people to do.
We,
it is our responsibility be coming
from the center of the universe here,
Silicon Valley,
uh,
that it's our responsibility to sort
of lead that transition for the,
certainly the United States,
the global workforce into that
new state where work is very,
very different.
Um,
one of the ways works is very
different is, is sort of grounded in,
in Internet of things,
right?
The cyber physical system
that coming together of, um,
of these two worlds.
Um,
certainly I don't need
to tell you about this,
but this puts us in technology in a
good place because we understand this,
we understand the impact
that this has on jobs, um,
and how Iot is displacing a lot of,
um,
traditional sort of blue collar, high
school education type of jobs. Um,
and, um, that is creating
a pretty significant, um,
divide and a is a really an opportunity
for us to sort of step up and help
bridge this gap and bring
more people along. Um,
just a quick case study
of, um, of tech, right?
So in this 25 year period,
um,
we saw a real shift in how,
uh, the economy, you know,
sort of major economic forces happen
in the United States and in the world.
Um, it's fantastic for shareholders. Um,
but there's a pretty significant
impact on workers, right?
So in this 25 years, about the
same amount of revenue, um,
and about 10, uh, 10 x
less number of employees,
right? Um, so a really
different type of work, um,
and a really different type
of worker, right? So, um,
uh, if you have an iPhone, you can
turn it over and it says Maroon.
It says manufactured in,
yeah. Designed in Cupertino,
in manufacturing in China or something
like, or, or designed in California,
manufactured in China. Um, so it's,
it's a great example of these
two different economies, right?
Manufacturing economy, the creative
economy, um, and the creative economy,
there's a lot more spoils.
There's a lot more wealth
that's generated for what,
for a much fewer number of people and a
really different type of person, right?
And maybe that was okay for a
while when tech was smaller,
but as Iot gets into
everything that we do,
every device, every Roomba, everything in
the world, right, is going to have some,
um, iot system in it. That
cyber physical system,
there's going to be this incredible
demand for engineering skills and just not
enough people to meet that demand.
So this model won't hold moving forward.
We won't be able to generate this amount
of revenue and this amount of market
capitalization with this few
number of people moving forward.
We'll need to expand
this, uh, this number,
this 137,000 employees.
Uh, just for comparison,
this is, um, these two numbers,
1.2 million employees
and 37 million employees.
That is the entire production
supply chain, right? So that's, um,
that's everybody who's making a spark
plug and making tires and assembling them
everything to the point of
sale. So, um, this causes a,
a challenge for us, right?
Um, we already know, right?
This is not new information that,
um,
1% of the global population controls 50%
of global wealth and 50% of the global
population has 1% of the wealth.
Um,
that's not new information at all. Um, we,
uh,
we know that rising quality and wealth
disparity as a significant a problem,
um, but it affects all of us, right? Uh,
because societies that have the
greatest wealth disparity also have,
um, the greatest instability, right? Um,
you can see here more violence,
more people in prison and more obesity,
a lower life expectancy.
Um,
lower trust in government systems
and institutions, things like that.
Inequality is rising in all countries.
Even those that have experienced
rapid growth and a drop in the overall
percentage of people living in poverty.
Right?
So this is something
again, um, the mission of,
of your tech company.
My Tech Might,
my tech company is make the world a
better place and improve people's lives,
right?
We're in tech because we have the power
to make the world a better place and
we're super excited. We're going to,
you know, use our passion and our,
and our energy, uh, to
help society. And, um,
so it, I feel a tremendous
responsibility, a responsibility, uh,
to do what we can to, um, you know,
to really further that mission.
And I feel like I can do that in my role
as the head of talent and learning at
SAP, which is a major
tech company. You know,
as we're looking at projecting out
the talent needs for the future,
the next five,
seven years,
I know how many engineers I'm
going to need in which countries,
and I know how many engineers are coming
online and there's not enough. Right?
And I know that the
staffing needs for most of,
um,
most of the other companies in the world,
major sort of players and
there's not enough people, right?
So there's a tremendous concern that
we need to do more to sort of help fill
that gap, right? Uh, we
know that, um, you know,
there's a lot of very exciting
technology coming online and, um,
great opportunities with that technology.
But there's also a lot of disruption.
Again, I'm very optimistic that
we can work our way through it,
but I feel like we need to do more,
um, to smooth that out. Right?
Um, so as we look at the
impact that technology has,
so,
um,
driver is the highest self
identified job in the United States,
right? So this includes, uh,
not just 18 wheeler drivers,
long haul trucks. Uh, this
includes taxi drivers, Uber's, um,
school bus drivers, city transit
drivers, private limousines, right?
So driver is the highest
self identified job.
Um, and, um,
there's an opportunity here
as this technology comes
online to be think about a
retraining and to think about what is the
education that is best for these types
of workers.
And one of the things that I think about
in my role is what is that cutoff point?
Um,
what is the tipping point when you
can take talent and transition them to
something new?
And when is the point where you say,
this particular type of talent is best
to learn not programming skills but
entrepreneurial skills because they're
going to need to do a little bit more
pulling themselves up and
figuring something out because
we as a society may not
be able to create enough jobs for
them. Right? So how can we help these,
these different folks? Um, a quick
story. My, uh, my mother and when,
Eh, when I was a little kid, I grew up
in the, in the 70s in Sacramento Valley.
And uh,
she was a bookkeeper at a local travel
agency and the local travel agency was in
the Mall Davis time for travel
and all of the moms worked there.
And, you know, that was back in the day,
if anybody can remember where you had
to like make an appointment to get a,
a paper ticket to go from San
Francisco to Frankfurt. And you know,
that was what travel agents did.
Um,
so certainly a huge change
in the travel industry, uh,
companies like Expedia and Travelocity
and Priceline and things like that.
So the travel industry
saw a huge increase,
but travel agents, right?
We saw a huge decline,
about a 40% decline from
the peak in 2002 today,
um, of that type of job. So people
who are travel agents, right?
Those jobs were all over the United States
in every little mall here and there,
and they were great middle class jobs,
a high school education jobs.
Um,
and now the industry is doing great but
really different type of job in a really
different location,
right?
So no longer spread out all
over the country equally, right?
Sort of concentrated in tech hubs
and different types of companies.
So my mom did fine.
She was a bookkeeper and she just went
and became a bookkeeper at another little,
uh, you know, business in town. Um,
but not everybody has sort of has that
resilience depending on the type of
skills that they have and what
is our responsibility, um,
to sort of think about and plan for the,
um,
the job changes that are
happening across the country. Um,
so this, uh, study was,
it's a 2013 Oxford University study
and it was praised when it came out for
being both, um, incredibly visionary
and, uh, very criticized as a,
as an alarmist. So it's probably
something in between as we look at,
um, the different jobs that
were, are likely to go away.
And we see the same pattern for every
sort of wave of industrial revolution.
The jobs that are most likely to be
eliminated are the ones that are,
um, uh, the highest in, um,
physical skills and the lowest
in cognition. Right. Um,
so, um, w there's also other, uh,
research that 83% of people whose
who are earning $20 an hour or less,
their jobs are likely to be eliminated
in the next five years due to automation.
Right?
Um,
the jobs that are least likely to be
eliminated or the most safe are the ones
that have a high amount of human
skills. What is uniquely human, right?
What can't be automated, what can't
be outsourced, what can't go online.
Um, and things that have a high
amount of human manipulation,
creativity, social perception,
things like that. Right? Uh,
we'll see a very significant increase
in psychologists, human resources,
people that are helping others
cope with change, right?
You have a thought.
There you go.
Job Security. Um, so, um,
there is,
you could probably tell just by reading
the news that we are at the lowest
levels of unemployment in a while,
but the highest levels of, right.
So we, we, we can sense that,
um, people are doing well, um,
but maybe underemployed and nervous.
Um, so, um,
our economy, um, and if
we look across a host of,
of industries is really in badly need
of workers skilled in computer science,
right?
Um,
they're half a million jobs going unfilled
now and in a few years it's estimated
that nearly a third of all
computer science related
jobs will be left unfilled.
We graduate in the United States about
43,000 computer science graduates a year.
Um,
and a 10th of all new jobs,
um,
are ones that haven't yet been created.
So we're looking for people
for occupations that haven't
yet even been designed.
Right? So, uh, another study that, um,
in in a f if you started a four
year computer science degree today,
by the time you graduate
in four years from now,
your freshmen content is no longer valid.
So incredible rate of change.
Um,
and really the best thing that we can
do for people is help them focus on
fundamental human skills,
resilience, creativity, innovation,
social perception, a cross
cultural awareness. Um, you know,
these are really what is
significantly human, um,
and can't be at risk
of automation, um, uh,
an outsourcing.
So some other stats that should worry us.
Um, we're not in good
shape globally, right? Um,
these are the 34 market economies that
make up the Organization for Economic
Cooperation and development. Um, and
you can see that, um, for example,
Japan always comes out on in the,
in the worst spot in this because they
are significantly high aging population.
Um, and um, and also, you know,
the increased life expectancy is making
it a challenge in a lot of countries as
we try to transition to
something that is new,
um, people are less
comfortable as they get older.
Transitioning to something that
is really, really new. There's a,
if you're born today in North America,
there's a 50% chance of living to 105.
If you're born today in Japan,
there's a 50% chance of living to 110.
So how do we think about preparing the
future workforce when our careers will be
50, 60 years long? Right? And you know,
what is the education that you need to
give you that foundation of resilience
and fundamental human skills
to be prepared for a very,
very long duration of change.
So this is 16 to 25 to 16 to 65 year olds.
But what about our kids? Right? Um,
fundamentally I'm an educator.
So given what we know about the future
of technology and how essential computer
skills are to our economy,
it seems pretty logical that understanding
the algorithms and applications and
the Internet is going to be
essential for our kids. Um,
health are there economic,
uh, abilities to,
to sustain themselves in the workforce.
Um,
and it's probably moving forward
just as important as understanding
photosynthesis and the digestive system
and, you know, electricity, right? Um,
so we need to really engage with our
school systems to understand how we can
create the workforce of
the future. Um, similarly,
when I talked about before that there's
sort of this threshold of when you can
teach people things that are brand new
and then when it's time for them to learn
entrepreneurial skills to create
something new on their own. Um,
because of the talent needs
that are coming online
across all of these countries
and all of our companies,
we can see a very significant demand for
certain skills and not enough graduates
coming online across all of our
countries that can meet that demand.
So we have to dig deep,
um,
across all of our companies and dig into
the k through 12 system to make sure
that it's preparing the workforce
of the future. 10, 20, 30 years out.
So, um, what's a super bummer? Now
we're going to get into this stuff.
It's all just a huge bummer.
So 90% of parents want their
kids to learn computer science,
but only 40% of schools
across the country teach it.
MMM.
And what's awesome is that kids that
take computer science really enjoy it.
Right? Um, schools that have
computer science and engineering,
the kids are excited about that.
So parents want them to learn it,
kids want to learn it. Uh, tech companies,
all companies are desperate for
these graduates to have it. Um,
we don't have enough graduates now,
but I'm not thinking about today.
I'm thinking about 10,
20 years out.
So that's why I'm focusing on this
population to get them ready. Um,
and we see a very significant,
um,
disconnect in the coming
in the coming years. Um,
this is not new information,
right? Everybody knows that
a lifetime earning of, uh,
a college graduate is a significantly
higher than high school graduate, right?
20 x is your lifetime earnings.
Um,
it as a college graduate,
but also as a computer science graduate,
it's 40% higher than the average
of all other degrees combined.
Right?
Um,
and so computing jobs are the number
one source of wage growth in the United
States,
in every industry in every state,
and they're projected to grow at twice
the rate of all other jobs combined.
Um,
again,
there's only 43,000 computer science grads
that come online a year in the United
States. So, um,
states that invest in computer science
education really reap the economic
benefit as well. It's not just at a
personal level, it's at a state level.
So there's only, there's only 10 states
in California, isn't one of them, um,
that have k through 12 computer
science and education standards. Um,
in 2017,
those 10 states were 9% more likely than
states without k through 12 computer
science standards to see unemployment
fall. So this was original.
So in the U S W I think we all sort of
know this intuitively that governments
and corporations change, um, at
a really different rate, right?
So,
um,
this chart shows the rate of change of
technology is the blue run here and then
the rate of change of public
policy in alignment to that. Um,
so what I am really challenged to do
and would love to put out the challenge
others to is see what we can do to sort
of close this gap, this change gap.
Um,
can we look at other sources of computer
science education to get more people
engaged in this solution? Um, I uh,
am also a firm believer that perhaps we
can do more in our HR departments and
our hiring, um, to meet
people halfway, um,
or meet people a little closer
to where they are. Right. Um,
this is just a quick
snapshot of Silicon Valley's,
um, community college system, right?
So some basic facts about the
California community colleges.
2.1 million students are enrolled
in California community colleges.
They are the nation's largest
institution of higher education,
114 schools. They are, um,
across California, 67%, um,
ethnically diverse.
Um, and uh, 53% female,
30% of all 16 to 24 year olds in the
state of California are enrolled in a
California community college.
30% of every kid,
16 to 24.
Um,
so that's across the state.
But here in Silicon Valley,
um,
we have 17 colleges,
263,000 students and
70,000 of them are in stem.
They are 71% diverse
here in silicon valley.
But what's super cool,
I think is that a 30% of the grads from
all ucs are California community college
transfers.
And 50% of the grads have all CSU,
who's our California community
college transfers, right?
48% of all stem graduates
from all UC schools,
Ucla, UC Berkeley, our California
community college transfers.
Almost 50% of every engineer that
graduates started in California community
college school.
Right?
So as we look to broadening our pool
of people that we're recruiting from,
uh, and helping more people
sort of move forward,
I'd like to challenge us all intac to
think about where we're recruiting from
and who we're looking for as we pull
people into the workforce of the future.
So, um, there are a ton of benefits, um,
to California community college
schools, uh, um, uh, kids.
And I should also say that it's
really tough to transfer. Um,
only 4% of the kids that are enrolled.
So 4% of the 2.1 million students
transfer to a four year school.
Um,
it's really hard.
And so you get somebody who's been
through the system and come out, um,
then you know, that person is pretty
resilient and smart and, and determined.
And so those are also
great characteristics to be
looking for as we look to the
future of,
of the talent.
And let me also tell you a reason
why I am super bullish about,
uh, this system as I'm
a product of it. So, um,
I have a confession to make.
I says why I'm super motivated about this.
So I kind of like barely
graduated high school. Um,
and um,
went to the local community college.
I grew up in Sacramento Valley,
so I went to American River College in
Sacramento and it was there that I was
diagnosed as dyslexic and
attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder and obsessive
compulsive disorder,
which my high school didn't recognize.
They just thought I couldn't sit still
and everyday I got wiggly and they would
just send me out to run the track.
And so I was super athlete,
but I really didn't learn a lot.
And uh,
so they figured this out at the community
college and they gave me the resources
that we need.
So I went from sort of deeds to A's,
transferred to UC Berkeley
on an academic scholarship,
and then a master's at Stanford on
an academic scholarship. So, um,
what does this have to do
with the Internet of things
and the automation of jobs
in the Future of workforce?
It's really about opening our eyes to an
alternative path and opening our minds
to what needs to happen if we're going
to have a strong economy and adjust
society, right? When we,
if we're trying to make a difference
about wealth disparity and a stable
society, it's about inclusion, right?
It's including all sorts of people from
all kinds of backgrounds in that future.
Um,
because there's going to be a lot of
disruption of a certain type of person and
we could do a lot more in tech
to include those people. Um,
I heard the term tech lash
for the first time in,
I read,
I was reading the economist maybe three
weeks ago and it said there's a tech
lash coming against silicon
valley against, by Washington.
And I was heard that for the first
time and I was physically shaking,
so I think we could do
more, right? I mean, I'm a,
I'm a silicon valley person. I said, you
know, Berkeley, Stanford, I'm like, here,
this is,
this is my world.
And we could do more to help people
in other parts of the country,
uh, to participate in the future of work.
Because we're going to need everybody,
right? So, um,
you guys are doing a
tremendous amount already,
so I'm not here to preach to you and
tell you that you should do something
different because you are absolutely
a role model in reaching out.
Um,
you have a tremendous volunteer culture.
Um, I was doing some research about you
and you have this great partnership with,
with goodwill, which I did not know. Um,
he's the largest workforce development
nonprofit in the country. Um,
and you've pledged $10 million and a
thousand Google volunteers to create
opportunities for 1.2 million youth,
formerly incarcerated and
displaced workers and veterans, um,
to give them digital skills to
participate in the future of work, um,
at the 156 goodwill stores across
the country. So that's fantastic.
That's fantastic. Um, so
certainly applaud these efforts,
but there's so many more things
that, um, we as a tech community,
um,
and we who are all sitting pretty with
our great degrees and our wonderful jobs
in our great future,
there's a lot more that we can do to bring
a more inclusive view into the talent
that we need.
So it's really about being open minded
to all kinds of talent and all kinds of
backgrounds,
right?
Look for those scrappy people that had
to pull themselves up and do something
the hard way because maybe they've
got some cool skills that we could all
benefit from. Um, encourage
students of all ages, um,
to, you know, it's, it's never too
late to learn something new and,
and to dig deep and try
and do something different.
And then my strongest call to action is
really around lobbying for k through 12
computer science education.
Um, and this is why,
even if you don't have kids,
right,
this is about doing what's
right for the community, um,
and the future of work because we
all want to live in a just society.
Um,
and in and in a place with that sort of
closes that wealth divide so that we can
have, um, you know, a
safer and more harmonious,
um, uh, environment,
uh, to, to, to live in.
So there are interesting
things that can be done.
It's not just around, um,
volunteering at a school, but,
um,
people who are working in schools,
they know that they have a
significant challenge. Right? Um,
it's not just going to the
school and saying, well,
why don't you just put through
a, you know, a computer
science, you know, standards.
They know that they should, why don't
you just hire computer science teachers?
They know that they should,
they cannot recruit computer science
teachers at the rate at which school
districts can pay, right?
If you have those skills,
you're going to go to a place like,
you know, your company, your mind,
and are a lot of others. Um,
so what can we do to, um,
you know, sponsor a teacher, uh, pay
for a teaching role. Um, you know,
maybe five engineers get together
and they all work a four,
10 schedule and everybody rotates and,
you know,
to actually teaches a class, um, you
know, there are things that we can do.
You can adopt a school, you can
adopt, you know, just like a, um,
a chaired professorship at a
university, you know, sponsor, uh,
the computer science department
out of school, things like that.
Um, so there's a lot that can be
done to get creative. I've been, um,
talking with different people,
um,
and at a national level around
creating social sabbatical programs for
employees, check employees
to go and volunteer for
three months and a government
organization, right, go, you know,
there's more that we can do, um,
to make our presence felt. Um, and,
uh, this is just a, it's not
just good for, uh, schools.
It's good for us. So this is a
quote from a Google employee about,
um, how this really changed his life. Um,
so I found this quote
on the code.org a site.
So I was super excited to,
uh,
to see a colleague of yours who
was making such a great impact.
And, um, and there's,
I want to leave you with some links of
things that you can go and check out,
uh, about ways to help.
So thoughts, questions,
feedback, ideas, reactions, anything.
Hr People, marketing people. Yes, please.
You mentioned,
um,
elementary school education and
then the community college scene.
But I also keep hearing that applying
to schools is getting so challenging and
it,
and kids have a lot of anxiety around it.
So is it also that we have to increase
the number of four year programs or is it
really earlier than that? It's,
it's earlier than that. I mean,
there is restaurant anxiety and in all
these levels and a lot that we could do
to make people feel that a lot of
different pads are worthy. Right.
Um, and make, I mean, w when
I keep, I have four kids.
What I keep telling, you know,
when I go talk to schools,
there's a lot of second
chances in this country, right?
You're going to have a long career,
right? You're going to work for 50 years.
There is nobody saying in their
right mind that you have to do x,
Y,Z in four years. Right?
Explore, uh, take risks,
learn new things, go to culinary school,
change your mind, do this for 10 years.
Go get another degree doing
something else for five years.
Get a different degree,
stack a bunch of micro credentials.
There's lots of different ways to get
to, you know, a really satisfying,
joyful life. There's not one path.
So it's kind of goes back to your,
your point.
Um,
I'm trying to encourage HR peers,
um,
to back off a little bit from,
it must be this university at,
it must be this degree.
Um, because I think we,
there's enough research
and data now that says, um,
there's not a direct correlation between
this university and this degree with
high productivity and high success. You
can get there in lots of different ways.
And sometimes the cert,
the Securitas path is what creates a
really interesting colleague and a really
innovative perspective.
So my,
my advice and encouragement to schools
is to back off on the stress and
encourage concepts of lifelong learning
and joy and internal motivation for a
long journey of learning and
discovery. Right. And if,
because if we don't have that from
within, we're going to be stuck. You know,
we may be have a great degree
that lasts for 20 years,
but what about the next 30
that you are still working
right.
Um, you touched on it a little bit as
you talked about the statistics around
community colleges in California,
but I'm wondering if you have any
researcher thoughts on as we're working to
kind of re skill or skill, the future
in computer science and tech. Um,
what about the intersectionality of making
sure that they're still that diverse
workforce coming up with that? Um, I know
that's a hot topic right now. You know,
do you have a diverse workforce and tech
and we're seeing that there's gaps in
gender or different ethnic groups.
So have you done any research into how,
you know,
you can skill the future for these,
these needed gaps,
but also ensure that you're bringing up a,
a more representative sample
of workers as well? Yeah,
I mean that's why we,
I talked about the diversity in the
California community college system. Um,
you know,
it's 53% female and 71% nonwhite.
So, um, these are great
opportunities to find diverse talent.
Um, and that's incredibly
important. I mean,
as we think about the role of
technology in our lives moving forward,
we can start to project out,
you know,
Internet of things and how
technology is in everything.
Do you want the people who are making
technology decisions to have a really
consistent sort of frame of
reference or do you want that?
I want the people who are making
technology decisions to have a very broad
background.
Um,
the often quoted example I didn't make
up was about a self driving cars that you
know, if a self driving car, um, is,
has an unavoidable collision
and there's a driver in the car and the
self driving car notices that there's
for pedestrians on the
sidewalk or whatever, um,
and uh,
collision is absolutely unavoidable.
Does the car making the decision to save
the driver who bought the car or say
you know, one or save the pedestrians for
what is the right decision for society?
What's the right decision for the person
who said, well, I bought that car,
you know, you choose me, right? Because
my car or I don't know. I mean, you know,
so that's an often quoted example of well,
who is making that decision?
The car. Okay, well who
programmed the car? Right? Um,
who hired that programmer of that car?
Um, what do all of the cars consistently,
what decision would all those cars make?
Um,
is that the right decision?
What is right in that situation?
Right? What is just, um,
I personally would like to have a
lot of diversity in the room when the
engineers are having conversation about
what that car should do in that decision,
in that circumstance.
Um,
so I think it's imperative
that we have diversity,
um,
and the new forms of technology moving
forward so that we have a greater
representative,
uh,
viewpoint in these really interesting
sort of ethical conversations that
need to happen. Yeah, please.
So there's a lot of companies now
with the massive online classes. Yeah,
sure. Of course. Sara. Sure. So it must
be a lot of students passing through that.
And it's a question for you and
probably some people in the audience.
Are Those students successful?
Have they learned,
can they use those skills
in a business workplace?
Yeah. Um, well the, um, I'm
okay,
I might get this little bit wrong,
but it's pretty close.
I think 80% of the people that are
taking moocs already have undergraduate
degrees.
Uh,
there's about a 5% completion rate for
people to start classes to complete them.
Um,
uh,
the number one class on
Coursera is how to learn.
So kind of goes back to, you know, what,
what is the most important thing
for us to know? It's how to learn.
You need to learn to learn.
You need to learn to unlearn.
You need to learn to relearn it.
You need to prepare yourself for 50,
60 year career because we're
all living to 105, you know,
of constant change. Right? You know,
retiring early might be 70. Right?
Um,
so how do we get ourselves in a mental
space as a society of constant learning
and constant change and being okay
with that and having that not being an
anxiety producing experience,
but a joyful experience,
a great opportunity. Um, so yeah,
there's a lot of people that are,
um, experiencing those classes
and I, they're great. We,
we do them in our company.
You do meet yours. Um, and um,
so it's interesting. I mean, it's, um,
I think that we should be,
um,
backing off on the pressure to have the
best degree from the best school and all
that and be more open and
accepting to diverse paths, um,
like stackable micro credentials. That's
great. You know, there's lots of ways,
you know, going to a code school,
they're going to a coding bootcamp.
There's lots of ways to get really
practical experience that is more open to
diverse backgrounds.
Okay.
I have a question. Yeah. All right. So
in today's world at big tech companies,
uh, do you think, um, suppose a student,
like a community college student
did complete a Coursera course?
Do you think that they are given due
consideration by the hiring team or do you
think there's still a kind of an elitism
towards prestigious universities and,
and, and, um,
what can companies like
Google and in SAP do to,
to fix that?
Yeah. Um, I, there's still
a us, um, uh, safety,
um, to choosing someone that
has a, um, a four year degree.
Um,
my perspective is that you should
be able to prove your experience.
So whether you have a,
a fancy degree from a four year school
or you have a bunch of stackable micro
certificates on top of a community
college associate's degree, either way,
you need to prove to me what
you know, right. As a hiring
manager, what can you do?
Um, so you know, more of a
portfolio approach to, um, the,
the hiring process where we're
talking about actual work, right?
Tell me about a time when you actually
did something right. Show me an example.
Um,
it's a great easy shortcut to say,
what school did you go to?
Um,
because we all know the vetting process
that goes through for those things.
But as the demand for workers,
it increases in and, uh,
certain roles we will need to,
we will need to expand our acceptance of
alternate paths to education for those
particular roles.
Um,
because the university is the system
just can't produce them and bring them
online as fast as, as they're needed
across all of our industries. Um,
so what we can do, your question is what,
what can we specifically do? We can,
you know, step back,
have a conversation as,
as an executive team around what are
we actually trying to accomplish?
What is our strategy?
What are our goals?
Can we achieve these goals by having a
broader perspective to talent and how
that talent sort of came up in the system.
So I think it really starts by us,
US as, as company sort of looking
deep into ourselves and saying,
what are we actually trying to accomplish
here and what are the different ways
that we can accomplish those goals?
Yeah. Cool. Hi,
I haven't seen any information on this,
but one way I would imagine
we could increase the
incoming pool of talent is for
large companies like Google and others
to put money behind some of these
schools.
Not for the reliance to be solely on
the government to support these schools,
but I'm not seeing, or maybe
they're just done quietly. But, um,
there was a time when I expected that
there would be Google you and it was a
brick and mortar school that you could
matriculate into from any high school and
it met all the standards, et cetera.
But the money came from within it.
Is that being thought about or done
in any way? I'm just not aware of it.
I don't know any, any plans about
Google you that's, that's not,
that's not anything I would
have a awareness of, um,
confirming Google open.
That's what I was wondering. Yes. Yeah,
I know some companies that have MBA
programs at the company pays for,
but they're full full programs.
And that's where I could see that we
could expand our Cape our capacity.
Yeah. Well, yeah. So, um, many
companies do this. Sap does also,
we sponsor five different high
schools across North America.
That's a partnership between the company,
uh,
high school and a local community college.
So it's a six year high school, um,
at the end of six years you graduate
with a high school diploma and an
associate's degree in computer science,
um,
and practical hands on experience.
So it's like an apprenticeship program.
It's this very close collaboration.
We have one in Oakland,
there's one in New York, there's
one in Canada. So yeah. Uh,
other companies do that too.
It's a great sort of first step
to making a huge difference.
Yeah.
Hi. Thank you. This is very
relevant and eye opening. Um,
so you mentioned earlier in your talk
skills for children, um, to have,
I don't know if those children
are all people in terms of, um,
this learning path and
you mentioned resilience,
cross cultural awareness,
creativity.
What were the other sort of essential
things to learn? Fundamental human right
skill. So creativity,
innovation, a social perception.
Um, the, uh, World Economic
Forum has a list of 16 of them.
I can send the, um, I can send
you the list and the link. Um,
uh, emotional intelligence,
empathy, creativity, uh,
listening, active listening skills,
leadership skills. You know,
you have fundamental numeracy, fundamental
writing, fundamental communication.
But if you look at the list of, of 16
skills from the world economic forum,
it's what is,
what really jumps out is how many
are and a human to human perception.
Um, yeah, that's, that's what's
really distinctive and, and, uh,
and different and exciting to see.
Wow.
Thank you. Ms Deerborne.
Thank you everyone for coming.
Let's give one more round of applause.